okay I think I think we are live let me
just mute this guy again here because I
keep my iPad beside me so that I could
see the questions that you sent it oh I
left my closet door open just a sec not
that there's anything particularly
secret in there just looks messy so
today I want to talk about where I am in
my 90 day challenge I'd be interested in
hearing where you all are in your 90 day
challenge some of the difficulties are
successes or or whatever and I want to
talk about this sort of the feeling that
I have about my language learning when
I'm learning a language right now I'm
learning too and that is that the
learning the language is like putting
the pieces of a jigsaw puzzle together
for those of you who are not English
speakers a jigsaw puzzle is a great big
puzzle where when you start there's
nothing there there's no picture there's
no image there's no landscape or
whatever it might be and you have to
pick these little pieces that have you
know they've been cut up with a jigsaw
and you slowly start to put them
together and the more pieces that you
have the clearer the big picture becomes
then the more you're able to pick up
other pieces and see where they fit and
that's exactly how I feel I'm gonna show
you the lesson right now that I'm
working on in Arabic by the way and I
typically spend the first half of the
week on Arabic and the second half of
the week on Persian and I'll show you my
statistics I have basically around 2009
words in Persian and around 8,000 non
words in Arabic and so today our
yesterday I was checking up my podcasts
al-jazeera cause back at phosphor CAF
had an interesting discussion with women
from different parts of the world
who were from different Arab countries
and they were all talking about the
Women's Day International Women's Day
and the status of women and what has
changed in different Arab countries and
so forth so I decided to get this
transcribed it's about a 40 minute
podcast get it transcribed using this
sort of automatic transcription service
and I've been picking my way through the
text and listening to the audio and I
find that I understand a lot of it not
enough to follow it but lots of words
lots of expressions I understand so
little bits of the jigsaw puzzle are
starting to come together I should point
out that the transcript is not because
it's done by an automatic transcription
service it's not perfect certainly the
punctuation is missing it's not ideal
but it's it's all helps me get a grasp
because ultimately what I consider to be
the most important sort of fundamental
skill in language learning is listening
comprehension so this transcript as
imperfect as it is helps me finish my
jigsaw puzzle the the goal and the
jigsaw puzzle is that I'll hear the
language and it'll be meaning that's
what I'm hoping to get to what's more I
know from experience that I will get
there that it's only a matter of putting
in the time as sometimes as frustrating
as it may seem going through the lesson
in link saving words not remembering
them reviewing them not remembering them
I know from experience that all I have
to do is continue that you know you can
do a crossword puzzle and and you're may
not be able to get all the answers you
may not be able to complete your jigsaw
puzzle in a real jigsaw puzzle if it's
very difficult but with language
learning I will avenge to get there
eventually everything will become clear
to me I know that it's just a matter of
putting in that
and that's why at link our statistics
you know are so important because they
track how much time how much you know
how much you're reading how much you're
listening and if you do enough of it and
eventually the jigsaw puzzles will
become clear and if you have solid
listing comprehension that means you
have vocabulary because when I listen to
my Arabic I hear all the words now I
hear them clearly but most of them I
don't know about so it over time as I
hear them these words in different
contexts and I see them and I review
them eventually I going to understand
more and more of them and as you know
the surrounding words better you're able
better able to remember or identify
those other words but I hear it clear
you know let me just show you a little
bit of what I'm doing and then I will go
to your comments and questions so I am
going to share this here and stop to
start screen share and okay know
presumably you are all looking at this
oh one of the questions I had was from a
person Joseph who is one of our my you
know regular here at these sessions and
he asked me if I could check of his his
profile so hopefully I must admit I had
forgotten and then I just remembered so
I thought I would do it so I go to the
community here where they have all of
you know forum discussions and stuff
like that and I enter his and hopefully
this will turn up I'll turn up there we
go
view all and here he is okay
so known words last week is not very
strong it's all of us unto zeros so I
don't know what Joseph maybe he's doing
another oh maybe it's because it's not
in Chinese I don't have to move this to
Johnny
Chinese there we go Chinese and here's
Joseph his now let's see that's me so I
didn't I have to go to the community
parlor me I should have done this ahead
of time so let's go there again do you
learn
I'm a bum here not you learns alright
that looks a little better so last week
he listened to 0.4 hours which is less
than we can see here links he's close to
known words is more than so he's
reviewing a lot of the words that he's
already learned converting them to non
presumably creating some links no no
he's you know he's going over words
presumably while reading that he why
don't we sorry let's start the beginning
more than anything
Joseph is reading which is good so 2660
were six words of reading verses the
target at 693 but the one that he falls
down on is listening and let's go here
for the last month 5.5 hours of
listening so lots of reading which is
good so he's more than exceeding his
goals in these other categories but
still falling behind in his listening
here again not very much listening now
we can't enter that to me so if I go to
Arabic the last month I have oh but
don't forget I'm doing two languages so
I have in the last month hours of
listening but if I go to my Farsi in the
last well 60 hours of listening in the
last three months and in the last month
17 hours of listening so between the two
languages I have 27 hours of listening
and we're here and Joseph is only 8
hours
listening and all in the last three
months in the last three months that's
not very much
so my recommendation to Joseph is
continue doing what you're doing in
terms of reading and reviewing but put
more emphasis into listening because as
I said I do believe the fundamental
skill is listening comprehension listen
to things that you can you have a chance
of understanding so again let's review
what I did I took my my my audio from
Hans about cat in Arabic and I posted it
to vocal Matic I got this transcript I
mean here's the text there's a bunch of
stuff they let you do I don't bother
with any of that I just copy that and
import it into link and so if I look at
how this is my should find out before I
go to the Arabic so I do have a I do the
Farsi and I just got a report from my
Farsi conversation which I have reviewed
I'm now working on these materials from
Persian online which are excellent but
let me show you what I'm doing in Arabic
so first of all I do have my regular
conversations with my tutor I have one
again at 11:15 with Dalia who's an
excellent tutor and but the this fall's
bad cats is where I have put my imported
content from France podcast which I'm
not allowed to share every pizza I don't
have the rights to it we're trying to
figure out some way that with automatic
transcription we could somehow have link
scrape these podcasts and people would
have to find their own transcripts or
something I don't know how best to do
that but if I look at this by the way it
says happy scribe because I went to two
different transcription services or one
deceased they were different or not but
you'll see that I'm working my way
through this there are 367 blue words
left I have gone through this at all of
these pages here and they're now all in
yellow and
so you can see that the the jigsaw
puzzle is starting to come together this
doesn't mean that all these yellow words
here are known to me it only means that
I have looked them up some are paler
yellow which means I think I'm getting a
better sense of them some remain dark
yellow and as of course as I progressed
this way more and more blue earth words
that I haven't seen before and that I
will convert to yellow and possibly some
of them I will convert white and so this
is this whole gradual process and when I
go through the whole thing and I'll
probably listen to this podcast snippets
of it because it's 40 minutes long so we
rarely going listen for a solid 40
minutes but if I'm on my bicycle or if
I'm cleaning up on helium 10-15 minutes
different parts of it and a lot of the
vocabulary repeats and it's just hard if
I enough I continue doing this for a
week after week after week there will be
fewer and fewer blue words you leave
even the yellow words will convert to
white and slowly the jigsaw puzzle will
become clearer
so with that I'll get back to the
regular screen and I want to look at the
questions that you have and tell me how
what your experience is with the
language learning jigsaw possible all
right now let me see what sort of things
we have here okay we'll go up to the top
okay we apply for volt and lane with
firefighter what's up my language right
down there okay find any sites that have
good Chinese count that you chose I
don't know it works well enough
does your wife speak any languages which
of you okay during a multilingual video
with you and the answer the second
question is no I'm sure this is the
answer the first question is yes she
speaks English and Cantonese both at
Marlys and the native level
she speaks Japanese very well she speaks
Mandarin very well she speaks Spanish
and Portuguese and French not as
in-depth as I do but when we were in
South America she was quite comfortable
dealing with different situations in
those languages yes what at least one
skeleton in the closet for sure you live
in Japan for much longer than France yet
you say you speak better French than
Japanese why is that well several
reasons first of all we had French at
school so while I couldn't speak on
leaving school that's it's in there
something you know whatever I did learn
but the second thing is when I was in
France I was living in French I was
studying at the University I wrote all
my exams in French I did all my reading
in French I was totally immersed in
French when I lived in Japan I lived
there with my family I worked in an
office for much of the time where much
of the communication was in English so
the the intensity of my French
experience was much greater it's also
true that languages that are
structurally similar languages of the
same language family are generally
easier I am finding that for example
with Parisian I understand Arabic better
because I have 8,000 words versus 2,000
but when it comes to speaking I I think
I find it easier to say things in
Persian than in Arabic because
everything about the structure the flow
is natural to me because it's
essentially of the same language family
as other indo-european languages that I
know
did you get confused learning such close
languages at once I don't know what the
reference which languages but if it's
Persian and Arabic then there's no real
confusion there structurally very
different there are a lot of Arabic
loanwords in Persian which helps a lot
actually
even if they have a slightly different
meaning sometimes and since they're both
written in the Arabic script to the
extent that I'm constantly reading the
Arabic script it's helping me in both
because my brain is slowly getting more
and more familiar with the Arabic script
if you were an intermediate level of
fortitude between only listing and only
reading which would you've used to
improve your local I don't know why that
would be a choice but I think I would
read if I had to choose that because I
find it very difficult to learn
vocabulary just by listening if I have a
lesson and my teacher you know if I say
how do you say this and my teacher gives
that to me in Persian or Arabic I have
no chance of remembering it non zero if
then she writes that out in my report
here are the words that I try to you
know remember then if I read it and
maybe review it I have to see it if I
can if I have a combination of both of
them I have a chance of learning the
words so I think reading is is more
important for increasing vocabulary and
listening is the sort of best
preparation for eventually speaking
listening also gives you momentum for
your reading as you have a sense of what
the words are supposed to sound like and
what's supposed to be the intonation of
the language so I wouldn't want to
choose but between the two I'd pick
reading okay my name is Monta from Iraq
I'd like to update what is the website
okay there are two transcript websites
that I have but there are undoubtedly
more if you google automatic
transcription you'll find them I use one
called vocal Matic vo C al MA
GIC poco mattock and the other one is
happy scrap pipe in our office Eric and
my son mark they tried both of them and
found it for Italian and Spanish happy
scribe was better so but you should find
whichever one works best for you is it
possible to read another language as
comfortably as your own
after reading at least 10 million words
well I can't comment on the 10 million
words I say that I read French as
comfortably as English I don't know how
many words are read in French once you
move into a different script so for
example Cyrillic you know Russian or
Ukrainian I find it easier to read the
Latin alphabet because I'm far more used
to it I've read far more in the Latin
alphabet so even reading polish your
check is easier than reading Russian or
Ukrainian even though I have read more
in Russian and Ukrainian that I have
polish your check but Japanese
I mean Chinese characters are because
I've done so much reading in Chinese
characters I find it difficult to read
katakana because I have them you don't
come across it very much it's all a
matter of you know when you say as
comfortably as your own I think the only
question is read comfortably yeah so hi
Steve from suddenly hi Steve I'm
wondering if you have any different in
Chinese through Lane and also how do you
tackle differences in sentence
structures as you don't get them in link
from Winston Churchill stint richer so
for learning Chinese through link of
course I didn't learn my Chinese through
link but I think I would have learned it
better because you can easily look up
words when I was learning Chinese either
had to use a Chinese dictionary which is
hopeless and because you forget by the
way as soon as you look up a word or I
had to rely on glossaries and they were
not necessarily didn't necessarily
reflect what on you and didn't know plus
that link you have the opinion can show
up
so I mean it's just a matter of Chinese
is no different than other languages you
have to read even less than a lot the
only additional thing with with Chinese
is you may have to put additional effort
into learning the characters you know
aside from link or in conjunction with
links or do a lot of listening reading
on link but then do have a deliberate
program of reviewing the characters how
do you tackle differences in sentence
structure I don't understand that every
language has a different sentence
structure you gradually get used to this
sentence structure through a lot of
listening and reading and you should
also get yourself some kind of a little
grammar book ideally one that has a lot
of examples and a minimum amount of
explanation in grammatical terms that's
how I learned Chinese I focused on the
patterns of the language I still
remember a Russian book I found that has
53
patterns in Russian so you just want to
see these patterns these sentence
patterns you don't remember it as you
review it but it does helps you a little
bit if you're struggling with some of
the patterns do you give importance to
writing in your language learning I mean
like other skills okay when this is from
khalifa' khalifa' when i learned
obviously with with French and Chinese I
had to write a lot French because I was
in the French University system and in
Chinese because that was one of the
requirements of my exam and I think
writing is a good thing to do but since
then I've been learning more from my own
amusement so I mean I don't write by
hand in Japanese not Korean not Russian
not any degree any of these languages I
if I write I write on the computer I can
get a keyboard for that language stole I
don't and then i'm writing as if i'm
speaking so I think it depends on your
goals if you have an academic goal or
you want to work for a company that you
do have to work on your writing and
writing is a good thing to do I
personally no longer do that but I
certainly did that for French and
Chinese
the writing out Chinese is really not
that hard mmm I would disagree it's not
that it's hard it takes a long time to
learn the characters okay my native
layer is Arabic and I wanna master
German can you get front in Portuguese
in six months if you already know
Spanish absolutely absolutely
however you have to do a lot of
listening reading and you have to let go
of your Spanish pronunciation and I find
a lot of Spanish speakers have trouble
with this you have to just totally you
know get into that Portuguese
pronunciation because the words are so
similar that you can just hang back and
say them as if they're Spanish and you
have to you know you and I have heard
Spanish speakers huh you know these pipe
casts that I listened to it and they
would some Portuguese person with an
interview uses an interview a Spanish
person who thought he was speaking
Portuguese but basically he was speaking
Spanish and made the occasional like he
would say father instead of a lot
fuzzier instead of I said but the rest
of it was just finished so the key for
Spanish speakers is to totally immerse
themselves project themselves into being
a Portuguese speaker but six months
absolutely you can become fluent you
think if useful you're learning a very
firm a different ways such as switch
every two weeks so it would make any
difference I don't know but I have
decided to do it this way I could
experiment another time doing it a
different way the disadvantage is that
just as I'm getting my teeth into
something I have to go to the other
language the advantage is that I'm not
far enough
I don't need it for two weeks so I
forget less and when I come back to it I
can pick it up more quickly
I'd have to experiment I can't give you
an answer to that how many links do you
make on average per day is there such a
thing you mean it I don't think there's
such a thing as too many links as to how
many makes I make a day if I look at my
Arabic now if I go to my profile
have a look I'm not gonna switch over
there as screens or anything but yeah
what is it
last week linked created is 675 in seven
days that's 102 then let's quite a lot
actually more than in fact I will I'll
just quickly because this is kind of
interesting as a secondary if I go to so
if you look at my profile here um okay
so last seven days and so you'll see
that my these are known words no I want
to go to links created so you'll see how
it sort of goes up and down this is
during this period 317 195 and then of
course down again 195 a day 45 317 but
of course it keeps on accumulate this is
from the last seven days I could look at
it the last 30 days and basically this
cumulative increase is what is gonna
make sure that you get the jigsaw puzzle
done and I know that in time in time in
time if I look at my Arabic over the
last six months you know gradually
gradually this is a period of great
concentration in Arabic just before I
went to Morocco but I have every
confidence that I will eventually get
there so let's just stop that okay it's
great to see where's Stephen how many
things Sergei Zharkov ha you see my
opinion when shouldn't understand any
parts
because it notes activate person with
Jerry what do you think hello from
Russia hello Russia I agree with you I
agree with you by the way my big regret
is in Russia I only visited a mosque on
st. Petersburg I would love to go and
see other parts of the country writing
is tremendously important it's a great
way to activate your passive vocabulary
because you have more time you can also
look up aspects of the grammar if you're
in doubt while you're writing it's a
good preparation for speaking the only
problem is that it takes more time and
though depending on your goal and your
patience and and how thorough you are I
tend to be somewhat lazy now I'm retired
I'm a dilettante I do what I want and so
I prefer I'm more motivated now for
example to read and listen about the
status of women in Arabic countries and
learn words related to that so that's
what I choose to do if I wanted to
become a more accurate user of the
Arabic language I would right so I agree
with you Sergei writing is very
important how do you stay motivated when
your parents don't support you in
turning languages you know do you really
need your parents to motivate you uh you
know when I was a kid I was interested
in lots of things that my parents were
not interested in I like playing hockey
my parents didn't play hockey I think
you know every person is an individual
independent human being they have to
find their own thing the parents might
be a source of motivation but they can
even be the only source of motivation
okay what are the corner of what you
what do you apply for solving dukes
apathy okay there's no solving the
jigsaw puzzle easily it's just this
gradual getting into the language
allowing the brain to create new neural
connections that enable you to control
this new language because your brain is
and
you know by the time you're seven it's
kind of or whatever the ages it's formed
around whatever your native or mother
tongue is and so you have to create
these new control centers for new
languages and it just takes time I don't
believe is a real shortcut there I want
to enjoy the listening of materials but
I stopped so freaking look at words I
don't get the whole manner from the text
what do you advise well that's why when
I'm listening I just listen whatever I
don't remember I don't or at least don't
don't know don't understand it just goes
it doesn't matter right now I'm
listening to Arabic I understand twenty
thirty percent of but at least I know
what they're talking about but then I go
and read and link and that's where I
look words up and even there I don't
fret about whether I'm gonna remember
them I don't try to nail anything down
I'm just I know from experience that
this combination of listening and
linking and viewing and reading and
gradually more and more things will
stick I have been learning Japanese for
about a year now but I've only learned
about a thousand can 800 kanji and still
find it much harder to read than to
listen how many can you do I need for
everyday stuff you need a lot of kanji
actually at least the two mm toyou kanji
and unfortunately the Japanese is
depending on the content use a lot more
Cantina the Toyo kanji is sort of the
prescribed you know basic level kanji so
it's just something that you chip away
at gradually people I enjoy what I'm
doing in Arabic I have no illusions and
in Persian it's gonna take me a year or
two I mean I spent four or five years on
Russian enjoying Russian novels
listening to Russian audiobooks yeah I'm
enjoying it so I'm not in any great
hurry and it eventually gets there and
and you're never perfect by the way
but when you I have enough say of a
background now in Russian that when I
visit Ukraine the second half of May and
I'll be in the eastern part of Ukraine
Kiev and I'll speak Russian and my
Russian will improve because I have this
this foundation of listening
comprehension and hopefully I'll
gradually make fewer and fewer mistakes
when speaking Steve I've seen some
people give advice my first learning
French not to do any
and folks not listening because the
spelling for suppressor is so different
what do you think no I don't agree with
that I think that you have to get a set
first of all as I've said I find reading
is the best way to learn vocabulary so I
think you should combine listening with
reading what you have to do though and
this applies not only to French but to
English for that matter learn to make -
not to connect the way it's written with
the way it is pronounced based on your
own language lots of people you know use
the example with Anna in our office who
pronounced sword even though it's sword
so you know word sword you know heard HD
ard bird bir d we have to become aware
of the fact that that the words that we
might in our own language pronounce some
other way we might pronounce bird as
beard bib we might pronounce querulous
widow we might pronounce word as war so
i have to use the fact that that this
writing connects to this sound and
that's why I think it's important to
combine listening and reading
what do you read an Al Jazeera Middle
East news so what I do in Al Jazeera and
trans fat cat they have a variety of
podcasts I can't remember I can't
remember what they're all and I have
them I go to them I can't remember what
they're all called if I hear a if
they're on a subject of interest to me
then and depending on whether I'm
already working on something else I may
get it transcribed this particular one
was of interest because it helps to like
if some of them I get they're talking
about you know politics in Iraq or
politics in Algeria and I don't know
anything about the parties in Iraq or
the names of people and stuff and so the
context is is too unfamiliar that's why
I chose this particular podcast about
the status of women in different Arabic
countries because and
that's all the issues I understand what
they're talking about and so if I can
get something that's a little more
familiar it's easier for me to follow so
that's kind of a strategy for me to
gradually expand my range of competence
in Arabic hello from Tunisia okay
there's a woman from Tunisia on my this
podcast about the status of women in the
workplace and stuff like that in
Indonesia happy scribe doesn't work for
Arabic it puts the words in the wrong
order
yes but the strange thing is so happy
stripes allows you to export it so I
exported it to technical texts or
something like that editor and when I
copied that and put it into link it was
the right way around this is a great
mystery to me I did it first with vocal
magic and then I said I wanted because
there was a few strange things I said
well test happy scribe and of course it
shows up on their website the wrong way
but by the time I imported it into link
it was the right way around so I thought
I had actually made a mistake and I did
it again and it happened again so for
some strange reason that I can't explain
even though it shows up on happy scribes
website left-to-right by the time I have
copied it to a text editor and brought
it in too late it's right left that's
all I can say maybe I did something
wrong
so hi from Kazakhstan hi Kazakhstan I
love Brazil
can you speak a great Arabic yeah la
está Tia and FL or della Robbia
but Ataman on a yankie new album Phil
miss dr. something like that I'm working
on it
could you recommend a good Japanese
learning book the one you use I have
that's so long ago I read up there was a
whole series of readers by a guy called
Nagas Numa that were all in hiragana
because I had the characters I want to
get a hang of hiragana one tremendous
resource that I used and listened to 20
30 times was show more nor kiraku it was
the history of the Showa era
I have books at home I'm in Palm Springs
I really can't say actually but anything
they're always saying just get yourself
a starter book and work at LinkedIn
you'll get there
can you give me a trigger technique to
master Chinese whoo there is no trick or
technique to master anything you have to
work on the characters can do a lot of
listening and reading hi Steve from
Vietnam hi Vietnam I enjoy visiting your
country I was in Hanoi went to Bombay
went up to the islands friendly people I
remember sitting on the sidewalk on yeah
these little stools that are very you
know a foot off the ground eating my
excellent yeah Abby's food can you
elaborate I'd like you called the
gestation period when learning a
language well there is no gestation
period to say but I have the feeling
that you know there is there is it takes
a while for the the language to gestate
in your brain so I have observed that if
I study a language for awhile and go
away and come back to it actually I'm
better so things are happening in the
brain that are solidifying whatever you
learned or it's so at least so it seems
to me and similarly if you say okay
instead of spending six months to learn
the language I'm going to learn it in
three weeks by working ten hours a day
you may find that actually there is this
gestation period which might be three
months or six months depending on the
language before these things are
properly integrated in your brain but I
don't know blah blah blah Nihao each
year 500 a teacher okay ah
yes geography and sanitary supplies
okay now geography and similarities of
language matter obviously if you have
anything okay so if we take Japanese
Chinese Korean Japanese and Chinese are
different language families structurally
different but 50% of the vocabulary in
Japanese comes from Chinese so if you
read Chinese characters it makes it a
lot easier than
japanese korean is related in terms of
language families to japanese i don't
find that that helps me so much what
helps me there again is that a lot of
the vocabulary comes from chinese so to
that extent those language influences
help loanwords help people fuss about
false friends I've never had felt that
that was a problem real friend false
friend anything that helps you remember
the word is a good thing
geographic proximity is more I think a
matter of motivation so I want to learn
Persian Arabic and Turkish because
they're very much part of that
historical you know part of the world I
may discover when I eventually get the
Turkish that there are loanwords there
from Arabic in fact I know there are
that I hear them say near no 'banahna
Turkish serials Netflix how much will
being fluent Spanish help learn French
will it have the time it takes to be
fluent and say whether it makes cuts it
in half the vocab sorry you know if
you're an English speaker going into
French then it's like 50% of the words
are similar of similar sort of Latin
French roots if you are a Spanish
speakers 80% or more the grammar is very
similar but of course it's different
some of the inherent difficulties of
French like the way the words the
liaison where they flow it to the next
word making it sometimes difficult to
pick out where whether word ends in the
next one begins those are gonna be the
same but I think it makes it
significantly easier because you have
all of that or capillary but it's not a
piece of cake you still have to work
harder ah lyrical sounds yes you do
entire okay alright
yeah let me know by the way BB if that
works with happy scribe it worked for me
I'm just wondering if I copied it to the
wrong place and I still got the original
transcript I just don't know but that's
what happened for me and do you know the
Japanese folks from shitty talk or do
you of course I know that song oh yeah
that was my standard song when I was you
know at the karaoke bar and I had to
sing a song she talked oh no Misaki need
Harman a suit or is it hi Steve from
London can you recommend some readings
to learn Italian well I I have to tell
you I recommend link there's so much
stuff in our in our website including
content from language learning websites
that make stuff available to us and you
can then go off to their website I would
you know Google Google whatever you're
interested in in Italian yeah that's all
I can tell you which language learn you
know that I don't know what is every
other mission but I oh thank you from
Germany all right and I do I'd love to
get back there too
do you think it's a good idea at the
beginning to learn the thousand most
common words that are used in a new
language no I don't because the most
common thousand words are gonna show up
anyway you'll you'll come across them if
you just simply get started with you
know I never teach yourself or I
recommend the mini stories in link where
we did focus in those stories on the
hundred most common verbs because you
need those verbs to say something go
come give get need want these were verbs
right but other than that the thousand
most common words are gonna show up
guarantee the problem is gonna be
learning the less common words because
they don't throw us off
so do you think that I think so I'm not
very but I can't say anything about it
hey Steve can I help you learn Arabic
okay I thank you for all the offers to
learn people who don't want to help me
in Arabic help me in in Persian I have
my tutor I'm going to stay with the
tutor in each of those languages I do a
lot of listening and reading what would
be great is to have add link some more
intermediate content so if people not
only in Persian in Arabic but in any
language typically conversations are
easier so if two people speak to each
other about their work day their family
life their children their what they did
yesterday what they want to do and these
get transcribed and if the sound quality
is good that is excellent excellent
learning material and if we can get more
of that kind of material particularly
for languages like Arabic and Persian
then you know that's gonna help our
learners because the difficulty is to
get from the sort of beginner stuff to
the more advanced stuff that I'm working
on right now like you know I'll just
hear a transpose I have interesting
kinda want to read but it is at 50% on
those words I really want to read it but
I'm worried I'm overloading my brain
with too many work what do you think I
mean it depends on your you know your
threshold of pain when I was learning
Russian and the time when make was much
slower than today I was reading you know
Virginia with 40 50 % on long words and
I just fighting my way through it the
advantages that I had the audio book and
the audio book was very well done so I
could listen to it even if I didn't
understand it was almost like music
because it was so well done so then I
was quite happy to keep fighting my way
through it and of course I it was like
short stories short stories like and
this was he was Chekov mr. Chekov
or was it Pushkin the the stationmaster
and there anyway yeah as long if you
have it's up to do something then go
back to the easy stuff and go back to
the more difficult stuff in Spanish why
would you use the in this sentence
one thing in Spanish learning is don't
ask why figure out what they do and do
it there needn't be an explanation
why is there in English that we we hear
someone but we listen to song why is it
that we tell someone but we say to
someone no reason that's just the way it
is
how's your Russian given you a leg up to
learn check of course of course because
60% of the vocabularies identifiably the
same hmm okay are you familiar with Anki
bla bla bla
I don't do a key because that's not
where I want to spend my time I want to
spend my time with interesting content
things that I find interesting so if I
had eight hours a day to spend on
language learning I might do some Anki
type activity but I have an hour to a
lot of it is listening so that's where
my focus is to do at the embroidery less
a border companies go and earn some tea
or a bit tired a target yeah I do should
we study them both Cantonese and
Mandarin at the same time or take one of
the time you know I really don't know I
have always so if we get back to that
the jigsaw puzzle if I were only doing
Arabic right now I would learn Arabic
faster my jigsaw puzzle would be
finished sooner I it's so difficult to
say sometimes it can help to do them at
the same time I would gold Mandarin
first I would go Mandarin first bit
defensive again where your interest is
which is more important to you know what
in the end I would experiment I would
experiment doing them both and then if I
find that you're drawn to one more than
to the other than I would go and do that
one I guess that's the best answer yeah
how do you schedule your language study
okay so
I have no schedule I don't go to college
I don't work I'm retired
typically I will listen for I'll get out
of bed before my wife I go out I cut up
some fruit that prepares some porridge
or whatever I get the coffee ready and
stuff like that 20 minutes or so I might
empty the dishwasher from the night
before 20 minutes 30 minutes I'm
listening
then I might have you know a session
right now or a session with my tutor but
I want to work in some time reading so
I'll either get in a half-hour or so or
more in the morning then we're off we
play golf with shopping we meet with
friends whatever and then in the evening
I like to get in maybe another half hour
or so of reading and linking and
wherever I if I go and work out at the
gym I will listen if I have to go
shopping and if my wife doesn't come
with me if I'm on my own I listen if I'm
with my wife I can't do that so it's
it's all pretty well random I second the
request for an hour of it yeah please
any of you out there who wanna help and
even if you only want to give us the
audio I can get a transcribe now
although it's better if you transcribe
it because you can then control the
accuracy of the transcription so yeah we
would love to see more intermediate
material for Arabic that you are thank
you hi Steve I have moved from UK to
Tenerife in but here they leave the S
off a lot of words who know okay yeah I
know that and that also had happens in
the southern part of Spain or in some
parts of Latin America I would focus on
the standard form of Spanish and there's
lots of content at link elsewhere on the
Internet
even when I lived in Japan I did a lot
of listening on my own lots and lots of
listening it's more difficult to rely on
the locals to really learn the language
when you get to a certain level you can
then go and interact with the locals and
you're very quick once you have a solid
base in the language you know enough of
the context that the missing SS don't
bother you okay how can you practice the
language that trip abroad when the
people accompanied you speak your native
land
such as mimics and very good question
I had that experience traveling in Latin
America with my wife
the only opportunity I had was sitting
in the front seat of the taxi good we
were traveling with another couple so we
were speaking English all the time they
only had time I had this practice
Spanish or Portuguese was sitting in the
front seat with the taxi driver that's a
problem if you're on your own
you have more opportunity that's why one
shouldn't put too much sort of an
emphasis even say and I studied check
for a year and then I went to Prague I
lined up people that I can speak to
people that I had he had as tutors
online I made sure I had an hour with
each everyday and then I was fortunate
enough you know I met with some linked
members and stuff so I lined up four or
five hours a day of speaking Czech
otherwise just to arrive and expect that
you can find people to talk to is a bit
unrealistic how did you study the
stationery man I'm in the same position
hard contents and I have the the
stationery man I don't know what that is
well if you burn out or you study very
hard in a language every day keep it
interesting keep it interesting go with
what motivates you and if you feel
burned out let it go for a couple days
how old from India hot India you know
I'm gonna learn Hindi I think but I'm
gonna go my strategy maybe Persian
Turkish and then with Persian slide into
you do and maybe do or do and Hindi at
the same time but that's in the future I
said then we can share lessons that
don't include audio I've got lots of
intimate me okay first of all you can
only share material for which you have
the copyright that's number one if you
have material for which you have the
copyright or there is no copyright if
you can find a native speaker to record
it then you can share it but the key
issue is you can't share material for
which you don't have a copyright
fighting a difficult learn Saudi Arabic
can't find much media that isn't MSA
yeah the media is all NSA if you can
find some of your Saudi friends who will
record material in Saudi Arabic we will
put it up at link but we'll need audio
and
and we just put it in the Arabic section
we have Levantine Arabic there we have
some Egyptian Arabic there so Iraqi
Arabic Saudi Arabic whatever if you can
find people that'll record themselves
we'll put it up alright how long did it
take you to learn Japanese after Chinese
and a link support hasn't contact me
back from my email is there a phone
number to call no there isn't a phone
number but Eric is following this and
he'll follow up with you I don't know
what the issue is but we will follow up
with you I mean how long did it take you
to learn Japanese like what does that
mean I was speaking within six months
and after four or five years I still had
trouble following the television so you
know it's a gradual gradual process can
you learn three languages at the same
time I haven't tried it I don't know how
many children have you got and do they
study languages like you from Mohammed
yeah I have two kids they're 49 and 48 I
have five grandchildren my youngest son
mark is the basically CEO of link he has
done all of the conceptual work for link
he coordinates our programmers he does
all of that and he speaks I would say
five languages
my older son lives in London England and
he is not particularly interested in
languages our grandchildren have learned
languages our three Canadian
grandchildren went to French immersion
the two kids in London they get it at
school but they're not crazy language
learners like grandpa can you learn
Chinese him when you're with hard work
yes I feel that I did it I did it in
less than one year but I was working
seven hours a day okay I'm gonna stop it
there it's been great and you can any
additional questions you can put them on
the
the youtube comment section and I will
try to answer them and Joseph I will
find out why you didn't get an answer
from a support alright then bye for now